without the weather what would the
british have to talk about and indeed
how would they spend their time because
we're an eccentric bunch aren't we
fiona's one of the wait for it swimmers
that you heard it right one of the
swimmers who's come down to brighton
beach today to take daily exercise
actually you come here most days and uh
i suppose you can do this because it's
actually quite mild really isn't it but
you're clearly still a lunatic oh still
very mild out there and yeah and the air
temperature is extremely mild as well so
it makes it more even more bearable but
i mean as our cameraman looks beyond you
into the roiling broiling serve
it doesn't look very appealing fiona
it's incredible yeah it's oh it's a
thrill
burster isn't it i mean it's what we do
it for we just you know it's just
dynamic you've got a little gang of what
about a dozen or so hardy swimmers who
turn who turn up most days what a
fantastic form of exercise it is yeah
normally we swim around the pier
traditionally or depending on what we
want to do we'll swim between the piers
but yeah and on a day like this it's
just a coin shower
we're trying to get a sense and it's
obviously difficult it's dramatically
unscientific of how bad this is
relatively speaking you told me two
minutes ago actually this isn't that bad
it's we've feeling worse
not swimming worse but we've stood on
the groin in worse definitely yeah but
this is uh this is wonderful it's just
good
shower let's go and if you toasted it
thanks very much indeed so there you go
we're leaving you some images aiming
from the scene on the south coast where
wind speeds a little further along the
coast at the isle of wight at the
needles have been touching 99
miles per hour we've better retreat oh
dear dear me one of britain's finest
photographers who's been rescued from
the surf oh dear
okay okay
well there you go amen